Herr Konrad wie schätzen Sie die
aktuelle Situation der Geiseln im
Gasastreifen ein wiwierig gefährdet aber
nicht hoffnungslos es ist ganz klar man
sieht es ja auch bei der Befreiung
dieser einzelnen Soldatin
es sind die die Geisel sind auf
verschiedenste Orte verteilt
und vielleicht auch nur in
Einzelpersonen oder kleinsten Gruppen
Hamas hat ein Interesse daran sie vor
Schäden durch die Kriegshandlungen zu
schützen allein schon aus eigen
Interesse weil sie mit den Geisel
natürlich viel vorhat es sind 240
gilchalids wenn Sie es mal ganz
vereinfacht sagen wollen äh damit kann
man wenn man den Krieg überlebt und das
ist natürlich die feste Absicht von
Hamas dieses auch politisch zu tun kann
man dann zu umfassenden Verhandlungen
und natürlich auch Erpressungen Israels
nutzen das ist der Plan das war der Plan
und dieser Plan ist bis heute nach allem
was wir erkennen können auch an
Kommunikation öffentlicher Kommunikation
äh der hamasführung einschließlich der
hamasführung in Gaza auch nicht
aufgegeben Herr Konrad wir haben es ja
jetzt schon zweimal gesehen dass jeweils
zwei Geiseln freigelassen wurden in den
vergangenen Wochen was ist konkret das
Ziel bzw das Kalkül der heramas hinter
diesen Aktionen diese Aktion zusammen
auch mit dem heutigen Video das kann man
durch im Kontext sehen ist maximalen
Druck in Israel aufzubauen und
gegebenfalls auch weltweit aber in
Israel besonders äh äh sie zeigt has
zeigt erstens wir haben sie zweitens wir
sind bereit sie durchaus auch
freizugeben in Klammer wenn die
Bedingungen stimmen und die Geiseln die
bisher entlassen worden sind haben auch
festgestellt dass sie nach der
gefangennah manierlich behandelt worden
sind jedenfalls ist das das was wir in
der Öffentlichkeit gehört haben auch die
Soldatin die jetzt befreit worden ist
hat sich ja wohl dem Vernehmen nach in
einem Gott se loben guten Zustand
befunden äh das ze t auch davon aus der
maßsicht
im Grunde machen wir das so wie bei Gil
Chalid vor 12 Jahren auch der war in
einem manierlichen Zustand nicht also an
uns Hamas soll es nicht liegen es liegt
ausschließlich an der Regierung
Netanyahu die uns bekämpft und die die
Geiseln eben nicht freilassen also uns V
dran hintert die Geisel frei zuulassen
aber das bedeutet wenn ich ihn zuhöre
dass für viele Geiseln und die vor allem
die die da nicht das Glück haben bei
solchen Aktionen freigelassen zu werden
dass denen möglicherweise noch eine
lange Gefangenschaft bevorsteht richtig
das steht zu befürchten die israelische
Armee ich habe es e gesagt die weitet
ihre Angriffe im Moment aus zum einen
auf dem Boden zum anderen auch aus der
Luft was bedeutet dieses Vorgehen
konkret für die Geiseln im
gaserastreifen ist sie ausweiten ist ein
weiter und unbestimmter Begriff es ist
ganz klar die israelischen Streitkräfte
gehen Schritt für Schritt vor das heißt
Sie können auch gar nicht anders als
Schritt für Schritt vorgehen angesichts
der taktischen Lage äh das heißt es
bleibt normalerweise Zeit genug für
Hamas wenn nötig Geiseln aus exponierten
Positionen auch zurückzuziehen und damit
wieder vorläufig zu sichern das ist
wahrscheinlich dass das Hamas machen
wird einfach wie ich schon sagte aus
ihrem eigenen Interesse
heraus wie realistisch ist es denn wir
haben jetzt gesehen es ist in der
vergangenen Nacht gelungen diese
Soldatin zu befreien das weitere soll
das weitere Geiseln durch eben
militärische Operationen in nah Zukunft
frei wie schätzen Sie das ein da es wäre
wichtig hier natürlich ein bisschen mehr
Details zu wissen unter welchen
Umständen jetzt die junge Dame
freigekommen ist od wie sie befreit
worden ist das kann je nachdem wie
geieln verteilt worden sind
möglicherweise ist sie verlassen worden
dass die hamasis die Flucht ergriffen
haben nicht sie einfachag hinterlassen
haben das wäen wichtige Elemente oder
war es wirklich ein aktiver Zugriff der
so geschickt war dass die Geisel e in
der Tat nicht zu Schaden gekommen ist
das kann im Einzelfall immer wieder
passieren aber es reines Lotteriespiel
da können wir als Außenstehende
überhaupt nichts Vernünftiges zu sagen
mhm die israelische Armee die hat jetzt
immer wieder gemeldet ranghohe Vertreter
der Hamas getötet zu haben aber offenbar
haben die Hamas als Reaktion anders als
Sie es vielleicht mal angekündigt hatten
bisher keine Geiseln getötet wie ist das
einzuschätzen
ja hochrangig ist auch ein relativer
Begriff natürlich waren das wenn Sie
wollen Kommandeure
ähm aber die sind dazu da zu kämpfen und
ich sag's etwas gemein nicht war eben
dann auch zu fallen gegenüber den fein
deswegen wird man nicht Geiseln
ostentativ töten sie müssten das ja auch
vorher angekündigt haben oder jetzt
zumindest als eine Reaktion
nehmen das sind die Verluste die im
Krieg auch aus Hamas Sicht erstmal
hinzunehmen sind die Geiseln werden für
besseres
aufgespart sie sind ich habe es Eingang
schon gesagt natürlich absoluter
Fachmann wenn es darum geht diplomat
Lösung zu finden bzw zu vermitteln über
die militärischen Operation haben wir
jetzt gesprochen lassen uns dann einmal
auf diplomatische Möglichkeiten schauen
wie viel Spielraum welchen Raum für
Verhandlung sehen sie da
gegenwärtig gegenwärtig letztenendes nur
Gespräche über z.B eine vorfristige
Freilassung eines Teils der Geiseln also
z.B Frauen Kinder Kranke das wäre
sinnvoll auch unter dem Aspekt das has
wie soll man sagen die Fürsorge ja die
ja durchaus aufwendig ist für diesen
Personenkreis los würde und wenn man das
auf mehrere Dutzend Personen schätzen
würde dann wäre das etwas was Heras im
Gegenzug zu einer taktischen
Erleichterung im auf dem Kriegschauplatz
z.B anbieten könnte oder für zusätzliche
humanitäre Hilfe für die Bevölkerung
denn das ist für has auf Dauer auch kein
Zustand dass eben die Bevölkerung
oberirdisch wegstirbt sage ich jetzt mal
oder eben katastrophale noch
katastrophalere Verhältnisse geschehen
das kann auch im Eigeninteresse von der
Maß nicht sein sie wissen also sie haben
bestimmt gehört dass ja schon die
letzten Tage wenn nicht eine Woche oder
mehr über Qatar solche Gespräche
gelaufen sein sollen ähm wie weit die
gedienen sind und ob sie sogar mal zu
einem taktisch überraschenden Durchbruch
kommen da das kann passieren das hängt
von der taktischen Lage dem taktischen
Druck auch ab unter dem sich Hamas
selbst fühlt und ob es die Chance sieht
durch eine solche Freilassung ein Teil
des militärischen Drucks von sich zu
nehmen aber sonst gibt es ja keinen
Austausch es gibt ja keinen Austausch
kein kein Gegenwert den Hamas hätte ja
für die Freilassung und die ultimative
Zielrichtung ist weiterhin die
entlehrung der israelischen Gefängnisse
das ist klar das
kommt nach Einstellung der Kampfhandlung
dann immer das auch ist Herr Konrad ich
würde gerne noch eine Frage an Sie
weitergeben die uns erreicht hat von
einem User und zwar lautet sie ist es
denn überhaupt möglich die Hamas zu
zerschlagen deren Ideologie lebt doch
weiter sie kennen die Heras sehr gut was
sagen sie dazu ja ich meine es ist nur
nicht nur die Ideologie die weiterlebt
ähm es wird durch diese enge
Verflechtung die enge Verflechtung von
Hamas Infrastruktur mit ziviler
Infrastruktur sie merken das ja das ist
ja das ist ja nicht nur dass es
menschliche Schilde sind sondern sind
auch infrastrukturschilde
äh wird es sehr sehr schwer sein
diese materielle Infrastruktur von Hamas
zu zerschlagen auch wenn sie sag mal die
Führungskräfte mehrheitlich aus auuser
Gefecht setzen würden wie auch immer
haben Sie Recht die Einstellung bleibt
bloß Einstellung ohne Organisation nützt
nichts ja wenn Sie also die operative
Handlungsfähigkeit der Organisation
Hamas massiv militärisch Schwächen hat
das zunächst einmal für einen gewissen
Zeitraum durchaus seine Auswirkung aber
da sind wir noch nicht es gibt noch
genug reser en soweit wir das soweit
vorkriegsschätzungen das uns ja auch
nahgelegt haben was also nun die die
Tausende und Abertausende von Raketen
angeht und weitere Infanteriewaffen
Sprengstoff auch von den Kämpfern von
her sind es ja wohl fünfstellige Zahlen
20.000 30000 sie haben jetzt Opfer
vielleicht in den hunderten vielleicht
in den kleinen Tausender Zahl das glaube
ich aber gar nicht dass das so schnell
so schrecklich passieren würde das heißt
sie hab müssen sich auch Wochen wenn ich
Monate vergleichbare Kampfhandlungen
einstellen in der Theorie ja um in der
Tat dann Hamas personell und
infrastrukturell zu zerstören da bliebe
immer noch der verbreitete sag Hass
nicht auf die Gegner aber den müssen sie
halt immer wieder dann organisatorisch
umsetzen und wenn die Organisation nicht
mehr da wäre ja dann würde das auch
deutlich schwerer möglich sein es wäre
zurückbomben ein zurückkämpfener Maß in
die Zeit vor Gaza wenn Sie wollen als
Hamas nur ein untergrundnetz war aber
nicht ein Territorium besetzt hatte Herr
Konrad lassen Sie uns gerne einmal
schauen auf die Vermittlung Verhandlung
die sie für die Freilassung des Soldaten
gilard Schalit geführt haben holen Sie
mich gerne einmal ab holen Sie uns gerne
einmal ab wie liefen diese Verhandlungen
damals ab und was hat die aus ihrer
Sicht rückblickend erfolgreich
gemacht ja ich kam ja zu einem relativ
späten Zeitpunkt in die Verhandlung sie
haben zurecht gesagt gilard schalid war
ja 5 Jahre e Gewahrsam von Hamas er
wurde 2006 entführt auch in einem
Vergleich bei einem ambush einem
Überfall allerdings durch einen Tunnel
seine Kameraden wurden seiner Zeit im
Überfall getötet er wurde quasi per
Zufall äh nach Gaza entführt und befand
sich dann die ganze Zeit äh imäh
Gewahrsam so israel hat dann über
Ägypten die ersten zweieinhalb Jahre
versucht einen Verhandlungsrahmen zu
schaffen der Rahmen ist auch geschaffen
worden man konnte sich aber über die
Inhalte nicht einigen das heißt also sie
wissen Hamas hat letzten Endes eine
gesamtsummer von 1000 Freilassungen
gefordert 450 äh qualifizierte HfTL
sicherheitshäftlinge die sie selber
vorschlagen wollte und darüber hat man
sich heillos zerstritten und in dieser
Situation als Netanyahu 2009 wieder
Premierminister wurde bin ich dann
sozusagen von Deutschland aus
ausgeliehen worden als quasi privater
Vermittler es hat nicht der BND
vermittelt die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland hat nicht vermittelt die
unterhält nämlich keine Beziehungen zu
Hamers die auch schon damals als
terroristische Vereinigung galt sondern
ich wurde aufgrund von früheren anderen
vermittlungserfolgen quasi als
Privatperson ausgeliehen und hatte ein
Mandat von Israel und eben auch ein
Mandat von Hamas um eben einen
Vertragsentwurf zu erarbeiten das haben
wir dann auch geschafft da ist aber eine
ganz andere Situation wie sie sehen ne
die ist nur sehr schwer mit der heutigen
zu vergleichen und gut das andere ist
wenn sie wollen einfach nur ein elendes
eine Shuttle diipomaie gewesen um eben
mühsam einen Text Listen
zusammenzustellen um dann die Kandidaten
die aus den israelischen Gefängnissen äh
zu entlassen sein eben zu identifizieren
ne und zwar quasi einvernehmlich nicht
und und das haben wir so einigermaßen
hinbekommen allerdings hatas zum Schluss
eben noch mal auf einer einem Zuschlag
von das waren zum Schluss dann 27
besonders belasteten häftingen besonders
großen Helden aus ihrer Sicht bestanden
das ließ sich dann erst mit
ägyptischer massiver diplomatischer und
ja politischer Hilfe dann
bewerkstelligen sowohl den Druck auf die
israelische Seite als auch eben auf am
Maß nicht noch mehr zu fordern denn das
Problem ist bei solchen Dingen immer man
kann ja immer noch mal ein Aufschlag
machen noch mal ein Aufschlag zum
Aufschlag nicht das geht ein bisschen
was geht bekanntlich immer nicht und das
war das was Heras natürlich wollte ein
Maximum herausreizen aus der Tatsache
dass sie einen lebenden israelischen
Soldaten in ihren Gewalt
hatte ja jetzt haben sie eben dann 230
240 Israelis zivil und Soldaten und das
ändert natürlich die Sachlage ganz
besonders verstehe Herr Konrad wir haben
noch eine Frage bekommen bei Youtube von
jmain jmain fragt welche zukünftigen
diplomatischen kamäle Kanäle so es
richtig können denn gegebenenfalls
vermitteln auch aus ihrer Erfahrung
heraus ja im Grunde eigentlich nur
Staaten brauchen einen Staat erst einmal
der desessen Geheimdienste oder desen
Politiker desen Diplomaten
gesprächsfähig sind sowohl gegenüber der
politischen und militärischen Führung
von Hamas denn wir brauchen beide die
militärische Führung macht nicht immer
das was ihre politische Führung ihnen
sagt weil die im Exil ist und natürlich
gegenüber der israelischen regier
derzeit sind das letzten Endes Qatar wie
wir sehen äh und es ist Ägypten beides
beides Staaten die über langjährige
Beziehungen jetzt zu Hamas verführen das
mag man bedauern oder auch nicht jetzt
ist es natürlich extrem nützlich äh und
das wird wohl auch der Rahmen sein aus
dem sie nicht rauskommen denkt sie auch
dar dran dass sie ohne Ägypten einen
großen Austausch und überhaupt in Gaza
kaum etwas bewegen können aufgrund der
Tatsache dass Ägypten eben ähm den
massivsten Einfluss auf Gaza ausüben kan
abgesehen von Israelis und Ägypten eben
in der Tat auch mit als muslimisches
Land auch mit der äh mit den
Muslimbrüdern die dort im Lande zwar
wieder unter Druck stehen gleich wohl
man hat gesprächsgrundlagen dann hat der
einen vergleichbaren Zeichensatz nicht
den terroristischen aber den
sprachlichen und
kulturellen jetzt kommt zum Schluss von
mir der obligatorische Blick in die
glaskuge bzw die daraus formulierte
Frage wie welchen Zeithorizont sehen Sie
denn da ist das ja worauf müssen wir uns
einstellen ja also wir müssen jetzt als
erstes sehr genau die einfach die
militärische Dynamik sehen ob das sich
eben in der Tat auf einen langfristig
angelegten Konflikt hin entwickelt
langfristigkeß über Wochen kann das da
ist die Frage die kann das Israel quasi
nicht militärisch aber politisch
durchhalten sowohl innen als auch
außenpolitisch ist eine offene Frage da
er zeigt die Erfahrung eigentlich eher
nicht aber wir haben jetzt eine neue
Situation es kann auch passieren dass
Hamas selbst um des eigenen
Überlebenswillen politischen
Überlebenswillen zu Kompromissen findet
die werden Ihnen aber wenn dann eben von
ägyptischer und katarischer Seite nah
gebracht werden müssen und Israel muss
mitspielen das kann also dann durchaus
wäre aber dann natürlich nicht das
erklärte Ziel von Israel sich ein für
alle mal dieser Organisation zu
entledigen so und damit haben sie im
Grunde genommen positive Überraschungen
innerhalb von Wochen und äh elendes
dahinziehen über Monate mindestens wenn
nicht sogar noch länger und denken Sie
da dran es muss ja nicht von vorin eine
Gesamtlösung geben es kann durchaus sein
dass wir erfreuliche Nachrichten haben
weil mit 50 oder mit 70 oder mit 80 ge
wir haben aber 240
äh das ist natürlich präzedenzlos das
wissen wir nicht insofern müssen wir uns
können wir auf einen schnellen Verlauf
hoffen aber mit einem äh langen Verlauf
müssen wir rechnen